this is a very simple test one thing
will change in this photo and one thing
only try to spot the change i'll give
you a few seconds to figure it out
[Music]
what changed see the clay plots on the
table they're brown now
before they were gray if you didn't
notice it don't worry you're not alone
in fact most people don't even if they
think they would that's the part that i
find the most interesting that people
think they'll notice things that they
actually don't you can make changes that
are fairly big i mean much bigger even
than the one you made and people will
miss those psychology professor dan
simons is famous for his experiment
where people were so busy counting the
times those dressed in white past a
basketball that they failed to see the
gorilla walk past in plain sight why is
it that we fail to see things that are
right in front of us part of it is that
we just have limits on how much we can
focus on and pay attention to in any
moment there's only so much we can
remember from a glance at a scene if the
visible structure of the eye is like a
camera lens then the retina the inner
layer of tissue at the back of the eye
is like the film inside the camera this
delicate organ forms an image by
collecting light reflected from the
surrounding environment but within the
retina very little of it is actually
high resolution consisting of fovea that
does complicated tasks like identifying
faces most of our vision is low
resolution so we can't see everything we
are bombarded by so many stimuli that it
exceeds the capacity of our brain so we
ignore most of what we see if you think
the clay pot example was too subtle
you're about to see one of dr simon's
experiments showing an extreme example
of how much some of us fail to notice an
unsuspecting pedestrian is giving
directions to the guy on the left who is
actually one of the experimenters in
this study a door passes between them
and the first experimenter is replaced
by someone else and the man giving
directions has no clue he's now talking
to a different person eight of the 15
people approached in the study didn't
know the person they were talking to was
replaced with someone else because we
really don't spend that much time
paying attention to the individual
features and characteristics of somebody
who's asking us for directions after the
change we'll say hey did you notice
anything unusual after those people went
by carrying a door and say well you know
that was kind of rude and they could
have gone around us but they really have
no idea that they're talking to somebody
else and he says those who did notice
the change continued to give directions
anyway because they felt the social
pressure too so what are the
implications of change blindness in
everyday life if you forget who your
waiter is that's natural it would be
easier to remember if something about
them sticks out and grabs your attention
like if they had blue hair our failure
to see change is why we tend not to
notice continuity errors in films if
you're patting yourself on the back
thinking you're great at noticing
mistakes in movies well here's some news
for you the people who notice them are
convinced that they always notice them
but of course they're only aware of the
ones they happened to notice they're not
aware of all the ones they miss there's
another more serious real-life
implication of change blindness it could
explain why eyewitness testimony may
sometimes be unreliable leading to a
witness wrongly identifying a suspect so
now that you're more aware of how
unaware you are time for another test
you're about to see two images switching
back and forth rapidly keep your gaze
fixed on the center and see if you can
spot the difference between them
[Music]
so did you see what changed if not pay
attention to the man on the right
wearing the jeans but just like before
keep your gaze on the center so that
only your attention has moved not your
gaze
did you catch the color of his jeans
changing from blue to brown now that you
know what's changing you can see the
change happening for yourself because
you're focused on it if you don't focus
on what's changing you're simply not
going to see the change
how about one more example
did you notice what changed this time
take a look at the boat on the right
it has now disappeared
seeing is difficult because we are
limited in our sight we have to let so
much go there are some life lessons here
too
perhaps what you truly need is in front
of you
but you can't see it because you're
focused on something else
in other words you may not have seen
what you truly need
i hope you've enjoyed this video
so does this make you a little bit
better at detecting changes maybe maybe
not for example did you notice that my
shirt changed throughout this video
leave a comment if you did turns out you
can get away with a lot more than you
think awareness is tricky to improve
unless you know what you're looking for
but you can improve your brain by
building up skills in math science and
computer science brilliant is a website
and app that makes learning stems super
fun and interactive so it doesn't even
feel like learning my all-time favorite
is their logic course to really improve
your critical thinking skills that are
the basis for mathematical reasoning in
this example you have to put the robots
in the correct order if you're ever
stuck there are explanations so you know
where you went wrong and you can explore
the laws of physics and the principles
of engineering by playing through their
scientific thinking course there's
something for everyone on brilliant no
matter your experience level to get
started for free visit brilliant.org
newsthink or click on the link in my
description or pin comment and the first
200 people to click my link will get 20
off brilliant annual premium
subscription which unlocks all of the
courses thanks for watching for
newsthink i'm cindy palm
you